there is and there is well Roman let's
go it out man how are you good Roman
reigns is here we're just talking about
a Anthony that's what we said there is
the guy that walked you in how a Travis
our producer has no patience for him so
I hope that he didn't wear you out in
the walk-in no he was fine
what are we talk to you about um what
did we talk about not too much actually
we're actually talking about the the
signs on the bathroom and so it was very
entertaining is it because they're newer
signs the bathroom is the new he was
sorry for those who can't see I'm
messing with headphones right now
we're talking because I get I guess the
woman had like an electric guitar yeah
and then the man was a cowboy right he
had the boots which I thought that was
pretty neat like you could get like a
Jack Daniel shot in there or something
like that like there's some weird like
saloon theme right but we were just in I
want to say have a Dobby here somewhere
you know in the Middle East or whatever
and they're there bathroom signs is just
the faces of a woman and a man and the
man it's like a distinct like goatee
it's funny how they did it just the face
and every man has a goatee and then the
woman is like literally wrapped up like
it's again wow it's just so like a
drawing of that I kind of like mine's no
address and there's no room for mistake
you know in there but only rules as far
as that yeah you must have been really
happy with your facial hair choices when
you got high I was like that's that's my
bathroom that's me that's the bathroom
how do you treat you they're like the
Middle East addressing is big everywhere
they how do they treat you when you go
there
excellent you know I mean they're
they're very gracious the hospitality
pretty much everywhere we go is you know
it's just it's perfect you know I mean
because there's always so much energy
there's always you know this huge
excitement because you know we get to
travel across America and you know do
our domestic touring you know year
around but there there's a lot of places
we only get to go once a year or twice a
year at that so you can definitely tell
you know and we're about to go you know
once we get through mania
we're going into torn season so you know
I think we have we have South Africa we
have Saudi Arabia with a huge job that
greatest battle royal of all time so
that's gonna be huge which I believe is
you know and I'm hopefully I'm not
giving you no spoilers your breaking
news happening now but I believe it's
gonna be a huge Network special so wow
you know how about if I I have never
done to buy I actually you know was just
them from the bathroom story but uh I've
been Abu Dhabi three times now so I
think what I Batali's what an hour away
maybe to two hours of if that but Dubai
would be very cool I would love to see
that City how far like ahead do you even
think about things it's like you said
you're like okay we got South Africa and
you got Saudi Arabia but before that you
got WrestleMania tonight you got Madison
Square Garden like that's what always
blows my mind that these things that
like we would think like okay I got a
trip to Saudi Arabia in like a month I
got to start kind of getting my head
around what I'm gonna be doing but there
are so many things that you're gonna be
doing before then is that something you
think about like the day before okay
that's what I'm doing now let's go do
this I try to get like a you know when
we want to get it we get our schedules
or so and you know most of the booking
you know as far as the live events we
have a couple months so you know in
advance like you know a quarter in
advance we know kind of where we're
going hopefully you know things are
subject to change obviously with you
know life and injuries and things like
that so you never know what you know the
card could actually be but you have a
general idea of where you're gonna be
but typically you don't worry about it
until the week of like you know when I
go home say when I finish this loop you
know through the weekend and Monday when
I go on Tuesday I'll chill out Tuesday
and then Wednesday my wife will be like
what are you doing I'm like I'm getting
this loop so you know ready I'm looking
at cars I'm kind of getting an idea of
the routing and if there's a central
point you know if we're doing you know
three live events is there a middle
point to where I can stay in the same
hotel for two to three nights you know
and like the little things you know you
have to get yourself a little bit of due
diligence yeah man I'm a
jack-of-all-trades we wear a lot of
different hats is uh
as inner entertainers in that ring you
know it's not all just you know trunks
and hip tosses it's is that there's a
lot you know we're travelers that that's
the real work as being a traveler but
this is a this is the crazy part of all
that is like should your figuring out
Wednesday what you're gonna do
Thursday traveling Friday Saturday
Sunday Monday on the road back home
Tuesday literally Tuesday is the only
time there's any piece where you're like
okay I can kind of veg out for a second
you got a family so it's not like you're
edging out Leah Tuesdays are actually
one of the roughest days because that's
a travel day you know that's it that's a
travel day so you'll get home you know
best-case scenario I'll get home 10:00
11:00 in the morning and as soon as I
get home
you know I have you know two two baby
boys you know what I mean so they are
very demanding so when I whenever I go
home I always make fun of Heath Slater
he'd always say you know when I go home
I just hit that super dad button you
know and I mean I'm tired but I hit that
super dad but I'm just father of the
year you know what I mean and so that's
kind of what you have to do because like
that and that's one thing you know is
I've always been taught when especially
in this business when you're home be
home you know what I mean and obviously
you have to do you know like like with
any job you have to have some
preparation there's got to be a little
bit of homework done you know to get
everything lined up to have a smooth you
know transition going back out onto the
road but I try to you know log in and be
there you know if I'm whether I'm doing
you know multiplication with my
ten-year-old or you know trying to get
my boys to learn how to share you know
you have to be all in in the situation
that you know that's at hand
what about like security and stuff when
you got a place like South because
there's some places that are just kind
of dangerous for tourists and you get
concerned about that you know we have a
great we have a great security staff you
know what I mean and that that's one
thing people you know don't realize and
and you you might be able to see it a
little more you know now that you know
you you you come around for the events
and stuff and then you're and you're
working them but there's a lot of stuff
going on backstage and there's so many
different you know crew members so many
different employees that make this
any work and security is a huge part of
that and they've run our schedule you
know what I mean like sometimes to be
able to people think it's just so the
wrestlers are the one these guys they've
rent cars and they make drives and
typically they have to wait so every
talent is out of the building then they
can get in their car and and and do
their traveling as well but it's very
demanding and and there's a lot of times
you know though they'll do the same
drive you know at that midnight shift
drive and then they have to be up you
know on a Monday you know they do that
drive Sunday they got to be up Monday at
like 9:30 10:00 in order to work
security for Vince and the rest of the
staff who are in a production meeting or
whatever that is that they're doing at
the building before the talent actually
get there so there's a lot that goes
into it and and they're just you know
another key example of just a strong
link of the chain you know how great
their security is if you go back last
year at WrestleMania they did a thing
with Gronk and Gronk was jumping out of
the crowd to interfere in a man and not
not all the security knew about it so
security guard
as soon as Gronk steps over the
barricade a security guard just runs
over to him and stops Gronk and goes
like uh-uh no way and like people had to
come and listen no no no offense a grown
but she kind of punked him a little bit
her name's Lisa and she's a total badass
you know what I mean and what's that
people weren't pissed at her for that
right because they she didn't know she
didn't know and she's just doing her job
and you know what I mean from our
standpoint I think just in general you
would rather have somebody you know step
up and you know come come to your aid
opposed to like yeah I think he's all
right as they're watching you know them
walk by to possibly attack you celebrity
he's fine no I think he's okay so
obviously we all know we're dealing with
entertainment but we're dealing with
entertainment from guys that can
physically destroy one another if need
be when you're going on television and
you're calling Brock Lesnar a [ __ ] two
weeks in a row on national television
and saying Brock Lesnar is a [ __ ] and
that's why it's not here is there any
part of you that goes like I hope the
Brock is aware of what we're doing here
and he doesn't take this out on me later
you know I think you know it's
a part of storytelling it's it's almost
like that uh you know that scene in
Braveheart when they're all lined up for
battle and they got the the blue paint
on and you know they all look cool but
then eventually they send out the nobles
to talk and then William Wallace is like
you know prancing around on his horse
and eventually he's about to take off
and he said I'm going to pick a fight
you know I mean so eventually that's
what this is all about you know that
that's that's the cool part of what we
do is you know we can build you know
this story through verbal confrontation
but at the end of the day it has to come
down to some sort of physicality it's
got to come down to that physical
performance but I've been in there with
a man no no no nobody's taken more
German I think I have set the record for
Germans at this point I think seen as a
close second but like I've been in a few
different matches with Brock and in a
multi man capacity and then I've had
this singles match you know at
WrestleMania 31 and Santa Clara but
that's that's kind of what's cool about
this this is a lot of times what we do
it's very cerebral this is very simple
very simple get ready to hurt and get
ready to bring it right back you know
what I mean
and we talked about I've talked to you
before about your match from
WrestleMania 31 about how I was there
and you could see like this is a sports
entertainment pro wrestling match but
Roman gets in the ring with Brock Lesnar
and they start swinging each other and
within 60 seconds of the match there's
already welts popping up on Romans face
like they're really Brock is not
breakfast isn't pulling you know he's
not pulling punches well it's gotta be
harder cuz he's also coming from he goes
back and forth in UFC so this times we
really really try he's really trying to
knock somebody's teeth out then there's
times where he has to just do it a
different way so it's guy he probably
hits harder than the other guys do and
there was also I mean you know and uh I
can't remember what show it was but
recently he's fighting this big guy
named braun strowman in a WWE match but
he gets i guess he got pissed at some
point in the match and the clips online
you can find it he needs braun strowman
in the head so hard I mean it's a UFC
level hard knee to the head and I'm like
oh my god you forget like call Pro
Wrestling what you will but you still
are getting in the ring
in a physical confrontation with Brock
Lesnar as our truth always says we're
not delivering the mill runnin like this
in my dad's only this ain't ballet when
when you come near this ring it's about
money and it's it's about this
physicality and you have to be able to
hold up and you know it's cool because
that's what I like about WWE's we have
so many different forms of tough guys
you know everybody can legitimately look
at Brock Legend and be like that's a
tough guy but not only the way he looks
but if you go back and you see what he's
done throughout his life the
achievements you know that the
opportunities and and you know the
different things that he's been able to
do but then we also have guys who run
around in little sex pants you know what
I mean and and it's funny because like
this is a story but III don't know what
I was I was you know my character is
more of a badass character a bit of a
stoic you know more of a walker than a
talker and I'm sitting there you know in
fandango's got his you know dancer pants
on and he's putting his oil and I just
look at him and say [ __ ] actually came
now is Fandango because he came in here
when that whole thing was starting and
he had gym lotion Imam I did he was in
the training room and I don't know why
he does this but he was rubbing vicks
vapor rub all over himself and typically
you put it on your chest or your necks
he'll open up your you know breathing
patches but he was putting on his
shoulder just in his stomach everywhere
and I just look at him and I just pot I
laughed I just started laughing hey just
goes hey whose it takes a tough guy to
do this I was like it all made sense I
was like you know what he's right ya
know like it in in different capacities
it takes a lot of tough guys a lot of
personalities to be able to to handle
this lifestyle in this crazy circus that
we live in have you I have you had
concussions I I have been very lucky to
protect myself and and learn you know
through our developmental and and that
that is a huge key I think to that
success for me is you know being able to
learn the basics and and how to protect
yourself while taking these Falls and do
the things that we do to make it
exciting
I have experienced them through football
and stuff like you play football for a
while why did you stop playing before my
memory stinks essentially you know
there's a there's a bit of a story
behind I'm not gonna get too too much
into it but at the end of the day
football was done with me you know and I
mean that that's that's the crazy thing
about the sport is it can be done with
you and and still keep going so that
that was like a huge a huge eye-opener
for me like it felt like it quit me
almost like I wasn't done but then it
was done with me how Olli I was 22 all
you really yeah yeah I was coming out of
college I played a Georgia Tech I was
going through the whole process and
everything I signed a free agent deal
with the Vikings and just due to some
medical things that set me back I wasn't
able to you know compete for a job there
and they ended up cutting me and I
bounced around a little bit and then I
went up to Edmonton for the CFL and
played for the Eskimos for a year and it
just wasn't the same the passion wasn't
there I knew I still wanted to be like a
man of influence like somebody that you
could say oh yeah he's a role model or
you know a superstar of some sort
somebody you know what I mean that uh
that is a bit of a household name I felt
like I had that in me but at that time I
just felt like I wasn't down the right
Road and there was a life change that
needed to happen and and I did that is
it hard like to get as psyched up when
you're in the CFL cuz all right guys I
go up there and make good careers and I
want some of them get back get into the
NFL but is it hard to kind of feel
psyched about playing football when it's
again it's it's a league but it's not
the NFL you know it it's funny to say
that because like that was one of the
sayings and I mean no disrespect to the
CFL I I'm very grateful they they help
me feed my daughter for a year and you
know it gave me an opportunity to play
another year and experience that and
experience so that you know a different
part of the world but they they used to
have this saying it's not the league
it's a league so which kind of sounds
disrespectful you know in a weird way
but the NFL is then FL it's a huge you
know it's a huge entertainment machine
you know I mean people look at it you
know a lot of different ways but when it
comes down to it you can't deny the
popularity you can't deny you know the
attention that it draws but it was a lot
different it's a lot different game up
there I was away from my family and a
you know a foreign city to me so it just
things weren't paying out I wasn't
playing as much as I thought I should
and I thought I was better than the guys
that were in front of me and you know
like anything else you either have to do
what you got to do or get off the pot do
you look back at all it kind of grateful
though like things certainly worked out
for you and again you probably avoided a
lot of head trauma that those guys take
and you wind up going on and do this so
you gotta be a household name for sure
yeah you know I think everybody has you
know a path and I everybody spat that's
why I don't ever you know judge people
and what they done it's not about you
know what she done you know before all
the time it's what you're doing and you
know like build what have you done for
me lately you're only as good as your
last performance that type of situation
so I think it all worked out for me and
I'm very grateful but you know it's one
of those situations you know you just
have to protect yourself you know
regardless of what kind of activity
you're doing what kind of you know if
you're doing an extreme sport and you
know all the way to play in an organized
league of basketball you have to protect
yourself you have to obviously know your
techniques and and and that's how you
protect I think your health and and
things like you're saying concussions
it's hopefully something that were you
know eradicating every single day and
every year we're getting closer but I
think the key is to start and the youth
leagues the key is to start young just
like anything else you know we start
school young so we can start learning
and and experiencing and conditioning
these ways so hopefully these habits
will you know become stronger for young
athletes there was a guy who was doing
and I'm sure you know they was doing
those jailhouse interviews trying to
connect you to his steroid scandal it
turned out to be totally false and it's
been proven to be completely false and
you know a guy doing jailhouse
interviews isn't exactly the most
reputable source anyway but when that
starts to come out obviously you know
you didn't do anything right are you
able to tune stuff like that out and be
like well I'm gonna be fine because I
didn't do this or do you start being
like
[ __ ] like I don't need somebody messing
with me right now like I just don't I
don't need to be thinking about this I
think it's a little bit of both you know
what I mean because you know at the same
at one point it's like who is this like
right where is this coming from whenever
I heard it what did I do
yeah it's like like what the heck is
going on I'm just sitting at home with
playing with my kids you know feeding
babies changing diapers and doing dad
stuff you know I mean and then all of a
sudden this happens but I think it's
just a good lesson of the you know where
we're at and if you have any kind of you
know media or social media presence or
essentially you know my twitter is a
billboard you know and I mean and and
unfortunately some people want to use it
and whether it's in a positive fashion
or a negative and people ever negative
on Twitter you know I have a pretty good
history with just being liked in general
but you know at the same time it's one
of those deals where I know what I you
know I know me I know what I've done I I
know what the truth is so you got to
have kind of a bulletproof mentality
where it's like these little things are
just ricocheting off of you
what's the pressure in like when you're
building up to this Wrestlemania match
with Brock Lesnar is the pressure what's
gonna happen in the ring or is the
pressure like look I got to tell this
story and convince a bunch of fans who
think that they might not want to see
this match why they want to see this
match like which which part is the thing
that you're like okay this is what's
gonna be work here you know the matches
the match and you know it's one thing to
speak about it when you're four weeks
five weeks out but it's just gonna be
physical
you know enemy I'm not you know if it
didn't broke don't break it if you saw
what we did you know if three years ago
you'll have a general idea of the way
the way we go at it I don't you know see
like we're not just going to give you
one of those were apples we gave you
we're not gonna just change the fruit
like we're gonna stay around the apples
and do what works for us because we're
both physical that that's what we do
we're both brawlers we're both physical
we're not scared to bang so if there's
anything I think the physicality
hopefully along with a great story
which is important you know what I mean
to to grasp that attention to get people
you know to completely you know immerse
themselves in it and get lost in it but
I think what you'll be able to take from
it is is that true
whoa right was that wait did he just
really did he just give him the true
piece did he give him the Stroman
through peace or what he didn't even
knock him out like you know what I mean
that's where I like to you know stretch
the imagination make people guess like
what man what are we watching here is
this MMA is this you know right
professional wrestling yeah if you can
kind of blur that line then I think
we're doing our job how's Ronda doing uh
you know I've been busy with the other
one you know and so but from from what
I've seen and the short hellos and you
know the small talk she's done good you
know she she's in a crazy situation
where she's gonna have to learn very
fast and and kind of you know like
myself and a few others she's gonna
learn kind of you know trial by error to
kind of you know be thrown in the fire
so she she may have moments where she
does really good stuff and there may be
moments where she struggles and you
might see that but as long as she's you
know having fun and she's progressing I
think it's it's it's a positive for
everybody having her around what's the
hardest thing to adjust to coming into
that world because it's def is different
than MMA is it the stuff on the mic is
that the holding but is it the the
inside the ring stuff what's the hardest
thing for someone from that world to
adjust to and they come over as far as
from MMA the hardest thing to learn you
think when you're coming out of that
background into what you're doing I
think there's a lot of different things
as far as you know entertainment like if
you go into the nuances of being a
character and and stuff like that but
the main thing is the travel is you know
as far as I don't know their schedule
and and the way they run you know their
regiment but it seems like in the MMA a
lot of them are in the same they train
in the same places they have their camps
you know what I mean so we don't have a
camp you know we we our camp is a new
town you know and I mean my camp tonight
is and the
you know and then the next night it's in
Tulsa you know what I'm saying so you're
just constantly moving you know I mean
if she has a family a husband kids she's
not gonna see them as much they're
there's a there's a bunch of sacrifices
that have to be made and and that's the
real work behind what we do so you
probably stayed traveling you stay in
all these little little [ __ ] hotels if
for a long time until you're well
established I'm obsessed with bedbugs
did you ever get bedbugs when you're on
the road terrifies me yeah I don't stay
in the crappy hotels myself but yeah
I've learned from early from early a
standpoint that if you're gonna like so
it's funny because like my wife and one
of my those O's wives were like you know
what I mean you spend $500 on a bar tab
or something or a meal but you don't
want to pay over $100 for a hotel like
well why don't that doesn't make any
sense so for me I take it as take care
of yourself you know get yourself a good
place get you some you know a place you
can trust so a good comfortable bed you
know somewhere that's safe because like
you said essentially becomes your home
you know I mean for a night and there's
as a world traveler and a performer
someone who's always on the road there's
a weird attachment that you can have
with a hotel it becomes like your your
apartment essentially so you definitely
want to take yourself like take care of
yourself in that regard for sure it's
very different from Mick Foley's
philosophy of sleeping on fan's couches
Wommack Foley was literally sleep on a
railroad spike $30 used to do the same
yeah he would just have a coat you know
like a Rolodex of fans that he knew over
the years and he would just stay with
them but I heard but Foley would like
before he like he'd be the main event
you know what I mean working who I rock
or whoever he was working with at the
time he would finish up he'd literally
get a huge thing of popcorn and he would
just drive to the next town and he just
eat the popcorn and that would be dinner
forms it wouldn't be anything on the
road typically yeah especially when
you're in the main like you're not
getting out of the building so about
10:30 11:00 by the time you do your
3-hour Drive everything is closed that's
weird how do you keep that body a lot of
hard work yeah you know to be able to
drive and
do the reach that's that's some sort of
calibrating I think so what's it like to
at this point to be doing for Vince to
be doing TV with him like you know he
doesn't really do perform on television
anymore but he was on Raw this week and
it made it you know a huge deal that
first segment was a big deal what's it
like to perform with him
now it's neat you know what I mean
because we've gone on a on a transition
over the years you know throughout you
know our relationship you know on screen
and off so it's it's always cool to see
him around to see him where he's not
just behind the scenes you know right
well I have to you know kick down the
fourth wall and go find him you know
what it means so anytime he's involved I
think it's cool and you can see that
chain reaction that leadership you know
what I mean when he's out you know by
the ring or if he's involved in you know
helping a certain segment or if you can
so he's super attached to something and
you can see that passion and that drive
of creativity that he still has you know
to be able to do it as long as he has
and to see as much as he has to still
have that level of passion it's
incredible so you were talking about you
just said you know did transition in the
ups and downs or whatever at the
relationship do you think it's unfair
that some people you went on Raw this
week and the promo is about how Brock
Lesnar is Vince McMahon's boy and that's
why he doesn't have to do the things
that everybody else has to do and and
there were people online that took
umbrage with it because they were like
well we all know that Roman reigns is
Vince's boy and he shouldn't be saying
that Pablo why do you think that that's
a fair summation of your relationship
with Vince so whether you're somebody
who's been in a situation like me or
you're somebody who is new or has been
around for a long time and hasn't quite
gotten the push that everyone thinks
they deserve the bottom line is we're
all Vince's boys when it comes down to
it what we do for him and this company
he has a huge respect for that you
couldn't be him and be involved in this
business and run it the way he is if you
didn't have the ultimate respect for
your performers for your talent
what we like to call we're called the
natural resource of our business you
know what I mean you can't you know you
no offense to any crew guys but you can
find lighting and you know sound guys
you know a lot of different places but
to find crazy people that I do what we
do it's it's not likely so that's one of
those situations where I think everybody
you know his Vince's boy everybody
should have that relationship
are we all equal in that regard you know
but to his point has brought down a lot
of stuff
absolutely but when you're in that
situation I just call I I think it's
just a matter of pride and it's a matter
of you know how you view yourself what
what do you see in the mirror how are
you trying to leave you know a place
that that you conduct your business that
hopefully you want to see grow and be
better when you leave and that's the
mindset I have so when I don't see that
and you know a fellow talent or up here
it pisses me off